Bud Light you may have seen this over
the last couple days Bud Light which I
thought you know we're always told is
the drink of men watching football
eating wings their new spokes man
is Dylan Mulvaney now Dylan Mulvaney as
far as we know we can Google it again
Brock you can do it today does Dylan
Mulvaney still have a penis Dylan
Mulvaney Brock Google it
Dylan Mulvaney is the woman right like
the trans woman who was in all these
videos who Joe Biden brought to the
White House and celebrated his or her
trans whatever okay fine but she he is
now the new spokesman for Bud Light I
don't know what Brock just came up with
but he's cracking up over there so I'm
going to find out as we play this for
you this is Dylan Mulvaney new Bud Light
spokesperson
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay break a leg
all right so let's let's put aside that
there obviously is some level of satire
there and he or she is trying to be
funny and whatever the point is what is
Bud Light doing by sending him or her
beer and putting her face or his face on
this thing and everything else does that
sell any beer right does does anyone is
there anyone on Earth who suddenly is
like
I do like light beer I like my four
percent Connor you're the Beer Drinker
here of course you're a Coors guy no you
like your ipas you like your what do you
like what do you like
Lagunitas okay Lagunitas does not have
a trans woman or whatever trying to sell
you on lagunit this beer it has a nice
hoppy taste a little bitterness it's an
IPA there you go but so what really is
going on here and that's what that's
what I'm saying this has more to do with
culture than even selling products or
anything else what has happened to us
that Bud Light which was it was the
football beer right it was the it was it
was for men and all that uh well now
it's going to this pretend woman who's
also at the same time mocking women in
her behavior is behavior whatever God
it's so stupid uh it's telling you that
something really is wrong with our
culture
oh
[Music]